-Welcome back, everybody!
Here at "The Tonight Show,"
we love songs,
and we especially
love songs written by
our audience members
in under an hour.
It's time for "Battle of the
Instant Songwriters."
Here we go.
-♪ I'm singing a song ♪
♪ And I'm writing a song ♪
♪ About another song ♪
-Oh, welcome to "Battle of the
Instant Songwriters."
Before the show, we went through
our great audience
and picked out two people
who said they were musicians.
We gave them each
a made-up song title
and gave them an hour to write
an original song
based on that title.
This is real.
Here's a shot of them practicing
backstage a minute ago.
Yeah, that's right.
I cannot wait to see
what they come up with,
so let's meet them right now.
Come on over, guys.
Welcome to the show. Hey!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Thank you so much.
-Nice to meet you.
-Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
Let's start with
contestant number 1.
What is your name
and where are you from?
-I'm Allie Chipkin from
Poughkeepsie, New York.
-No way!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, I got my start over there.
Yeah.
What was the title of the song
you were given?
-"Too Old to Trick-or-Treat."
-Ooh!
"Too Old to Trick-or-Treat."
I feel that way.
What instrument
will you be playing?
-The guitar.
-Oh, cool.
Alright, why don't you go over
and get ready,
and then I'll introduce you
and give you a good intro.
It's going to be fun.
Don't get nervous.
You'll have your shot.
Yeah, it'll be fine.
You'll be good.
Yeah, we got this.
And now, ladies and gentlemen,
here to perform
the world premiere
of the soon-to-be classic
"Too Old to Trick-or-Treat,"
it's Allie Chipkin.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ So what if my hair
is turning gray? ♪
♪ I can still get down with
a Milky Way ♪
♪ And I find the best treatment
for my wrinkles ♪
♪ Is anything with sprinkles ♪
♪ Now, I know it's
pretty early in the night ♪
♪ But "Jeopardy!" is at 7:00,
and I don't see well
in dim light ♪
♪ I took off my mask
so I won't overheat ♪
♪ Did you say I'm too old to
trick-or-treat? ♪
♪ Well, you can smell my feet ♪
♪ You don't own this treat ♪
♪ You can smell my feet ♪
♪ I'd even take toothpaste ♪
♪ But I'm not too old to
trick-or-treat ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's what I'm talking about.
That's how you do it.
Give it up for Allie Chipkin,
ladies and gentlemen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well done. Thank you, pal.
-Thank you.
-Contestant number 2,
what is your name
and where are you from?
-My name is Tom McGovern.
I'm from Allentown, New Jersey.
-Hey, Tom!
-Hey!
-Thank you for being here.
-Thanks, dude.
-And tell everyone what
song title was given to you.
-The song title was "Let's Avoid
the Weird Guy's House."
-It is Halloween.
"Let's Avoid
the Weird Guy's House."
And what instrument
will you be playing tonight?
-I'll be playing piano.
-Alright, Tom,
go over and get ready.
Whenever you're...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on over.
You can come over here.
That was great.
-Oh, thank you.
-Ladies and gentlemen, get ready
for the world premiere of
"Let's Avoid the Weird
Guy's House" by Tom McGovern.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ The sun goes down
on Halloween,
it's time to trick-or-treat ♪
♪ My friends and I
are all dressed up like
ghosts in fitted sheets ♪
♪ We go door-to-door to
snag some peanut-butter cups ♪
♪ Then we hear someone shouting,
so we turn to what's up ♪
♪ Some guy says,
"Hey, come over,
I've got all
the awesome snacks" ♪
♪ And then he hits a vape and
starts to play the alto sax ♪
♪ He's handing out potatoes and
some traps to catch a mouse ♪
♪ Let's avoid
the weird guy's house ♪
♪ We should find the house
that's giving
king-size candy bars ♪
♪ And maybe we avoid the man
that's twerking on his car ♪
♪ He lights off tiny fireworks
while crying on his lawn ♪
♪ Then he steps onto his porch
and starts to sing Celine Dion ♪
♪ He does this every year,
we don't know
what he's all about ♪
♪ Let's avoid
the weird guy's house ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Alright, very nice!
Come on over, bud.
Well done, buddy.
-Thank you. Thank you, sir.
-Tom McGovern, everybody.
Give it up for Tom.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, it's time to see who won.
We're going to let our audience
decide the winner.
[ Drumroll ]
Yes.
Don't be cruel, you guys.
[ Laughter ]
Was it Tom McGovern?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Was it Allie Chipkin?
We're going to give it to
Tom McGovern as the winner,
ladies and gentlemen!
-Yeah!
-Nicely done.
-Tom, congratulations.
-Yes, sir.
-You get a sweatshirt that says
"I love music."
-Awesome.
-Congratulations.
-Awesome. Thank you.
-We're also giving you
a notebook
so you can write more hits.
And in there,
we give you $1,000.
-Awesome!
-Come on.
-Thank you very much.
-Happy Halloween.
-Thank you.
-No, no one goes home empty --
You get a sweatshirt that says
"I love music," as well.
And you get a "Tonight Show"
notebook and $1,000, as well.
Come on.
-Thank you.
-Give it up for your
two new instant songwriters!